foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wilson senior programmer at film
Independence welcome to this film
independent presents q a for the
documentary the James by tlsson and Emma
pilbus special thanks to our lead
sponsor the hefpa and our virtual
screenings partner Vision media now
please welcome today's guests directors
Tia lesson and Emma pildus and foam
subject and original member of Jane
Diane Stevens
hi yay
personal Applause from me
um
I really appreciated this film so much
um
Tia and Emma do you want to start by
talking about uh how you came to make a
film on this subject matter
should be changed up why don't you you
want to take it this time how do you
make a film on this very carefully
um you know look we had very little
to go on in terms of imagery for the
pre-row era
um there was the coat hanger and all
that came with it and you know what Emma
and I were drawn to the story because
it's such a
extraordinary story of resistance you
know and
um
Sisterhood and it also is a great drama
and so we really wanted to lean into the
Caper aspect of this film
um into the levity of the of the women
of Jane
um and also really
clearly informed by the urgency of this
moment where as we were making the film
and as we were releasing the film
abortion rights you know we're coming to
an end in this country
reasons we wanted to make the film was
was for all of what Tia just said
um
but I have a family connection to the
film so this is something that I've
known about for most of my life
um and
you know my brother who is also a
producer on the film a producer in the
world and a producer on the film he
actually started developing the film
right around when Trump got into office
um
it he just saw the immediate need he had
the foresight I mean there were so many
things that were being threatened
pretty immediately when Trump got into
office
um and that the fact that he immediately
started packing the courts and had his
eye on the prize with the high courts
and changing the composition of the high
courts seemed obvious and
um
this was something that we had in our
back pocket in our backyard
um and that we could
use that that seemed of use to this
fight you know where filmmakers
um this is our skill set this is what we
can contribute and so
we wanted to give a platform to these
women these incredible women to Bear
witness and tell the story of what they
saw and what they felt and what they had
to do
um last last time 50 years ago women in
this country didn't have a right to
choose so it just seemed so necessary
and something that we could accomplish
um and because of you know this sort of
second
second uh piece of Bravery by the women
their willingness to sit in front of the
cameras and tell the story of their
illegal activity from 50 years ago and
because of the smarts of HBO and the
matriarchy that runs things over there
um we were Tia and I were able to direct
this film and
okay you know the film came out on HBO
in in June which is the same month that
we lost row so
um in the nick of time isn't the right
way to say it but
um you know it was quite an experience
to watch these two things sort of happen
simultaneously
yeah so my next question was going to be
did you have any idea that Roe v Wade
might be overturned by the time the film
came out so it sounds like you really
did think that it might happen by the
time this was finished
yeah it seemed you know look that
there's been a constant erosion of
abortion rights you know since 1973
since Roe and um you know by 2016 it was
clear that
that the the extremists the
fundamentalists had their eyes on this
decision and um and we were racing
against the clock and against the
pandemic to get this film out before we
lost the federal guarantee for abortion
rights altogether but we also wanted to
tell a different kind of story you know
there's been some great films about
abortion
um that that have been made in the
documentary community in the fiction
Community
um and the the story
um you know was a particular one that we
felt you know needed to be told in this
moment but we we really wanted to do
justice to it
um cinematically and filmically and
um and these voices I think
um we're just too
too important to lose
so this film draws heavily on archival
um it's fantastic archival
um just a whole lot of footage I don't
think I've ever seen had either one of
you ever done an archival dock before
and you want to talk about like what are
the differences between working on an
archival Dock and
um a dock that's like contemporary where
you're not using any footage from the
past
yeah well these women weren't filming
you know their activities at the time
they were they were engaged in illegal
work and they were all about the work so
they weren't taking photographs or film
footage so you know that was a that was
a fun challenge for us to represent this
visually without you know resorting to
reenactments we
had the benefit of you know delving into
some very very rich collections on the
Chicago historical society among them
and local news and television film
collections but Emma and I have had a
deep background in archival research you
know Emma with Susan Lacy and her
beautiful biopics and American Masters
so Emma was the producer of the Jane
Fonda film Steven Spielberg film
a John Lennon film so
um and and I you know have done a lot of
work with archival through my work with
Michael Moore and other filmmakers so we
knew our way around the archives and I
think the challenge was that we were
doing this during covid so there was a
bit of a limit to our access
with these collections but we found some
extraordinary things you know neither of
us had seen this footage before of of
abortion providers and the women they
serve being rounded up around the
country
um and and and brought to brought to the
precincts brought to courts and then
eventually to to prison and
um we really wanted to
um to to Spotlight that footage because
that that's what's going to happen you
know in this moment
um and but but this was happening in the
60s and we'd never before seen this
footage
um we also you know found footage of the
Cook County Hospital during that era
um again you know this horrific footage
of of of of of women who were harmed
um by botched abortions or self-induced
abortions and were dumped at this public
Hospital in Chicago and we heard stories
about it but we were able thanks to a
film crew that had shot the footage in
1971 we were able to actually see what
that looked like
which is just that our our editor
Kristen Huntley is
did such an extraordinary job with the
archive
um the care and Nuance of bringing it
all together which is very it's very
hard you know I mean all documentary
filmmaking is very hard but it's it's a
special thing to be able to
um
evoke a time and a feeling and a moment
and have feet firmly planted in that and
then be carried through by seated
interviews and it was so important to us
to to
um to really lock into that time and
lock into that moment you know to make
to make this moment real so that we
could
understand what it felt like and and and
think about it in contemporary in our
contemporary
situation so
I just just a shout out to Kristin
Huntley that just did such an incredible
job editors are extremely important
yeah especially documentary absolutely
and and we really wanted to bring
Chicago to life you know we wanted to
bring
we wanted to look at the context of
these women's lives not only of the
chains but the women they were serving
and you know the Civil Rights Movement
the student movement the anti-war
movement you know um and the City of
Chicago were just such a you know a
vivid backdrop yeah um to what what the
chains were doing um and we are grateful
to cartemquin pictures that shot a lot
of footage that we used
um from that time period and also to
Vivian Mayer
um whose collection resides in part at
the Chicago
historical society and uh to Joanna Lama
an experimental filmmaker whose work we
also Drew on as well as a bunch of other
that's amazing professional and amateur
filmmakers
um
so
I want to ask
um
for the for the for the actual Jane that
we have here
um thank you for coming today
um
I think that your work is really special
um oh actually towards you mentioned two
things that I was really shocked to hear
about in the film was that Cook County
had
a ward for people who had tried to
self-abort
which was extremely telling and makes me
wonder if
hospitals are gonna have to go back to
doing that in the current condition
and but the other uh thing that I
noticed in the film was someone says
that um
women weren't allowed to be pregnant in
the workplace
and you use an example of like a
secretary someone said
it just wouldn't have been appropriate
for a a pregnant visibly pregnant
secretary to be sitting like at her
typewriter
and I had never actually heard that
um
I'm a person who had a grandmother who
was like vice president of a bank and
you know had three three daughters
throughout her career
it just makes she's not alive today but
it makes just makes me wonder like was
she moved to the back
in this time Chris says this was the
time period you know like did they have
to hide her when she was pregnant so I'm
just wondering um
uh if there's Diane if you can give any
insights about what it was that seemed
visibly pregnant women in the workplace
was so unacceptable
well I guess I can't really speak to
that
um I didn't have that experience some of
the older women in the group
spoke to that pretty effectively but I I
never had that experience
um I'd also but I'd also look at the
issue of class like maybe a woman that
was a higher up in a bank was able to
get away with more than a woman who
might have been like me who would have
been on a much lower level kind of
clerical job but
um I didn't personally have that
experience
[Music]
Emma and tia did you have any thoughts
about
why women couldn't be visibly pregnant
in workplaces I mean uh well I know
teachers couldn't be visibly pregnant
they were fired immediately they
couldn't show in front of children as if
it were
you know somehow
portographic I don't know
um they're also I mean we we saw that
story told to a certain degree in the
Desi Lucy film that Amy polar made you
know that right
um
that you know that it was unacceptable
for the pregnancy
um to be shown on National Television
um so there was a fight that they had
with the executives
um and um they you know ultimately Lucy
was able to show her pregnant self but
right as if being pregnant was
considered obscene in that time period
kind of yeah I mean there's a lot of
things that we wanted to include in the
film like that you know like
you couldn't get birth control unless
you were married right so one of the
women in the film tells the story of
going to Woolworth and getting a fake
band and putting it on our left finger
so she could go in and get and get birth
control I mean it was just a different
paradigm you know and we wanted that to
be understood that you
that there was a time where you couldn't
have your own credit card as a woman
there was a time where you couldn't have
a mortgage as a woman that that because
in addition to not knowing the history
of of a of abortion and not being in
touch with a time when women didn't have
this right
so many generations don't know that
stuff either I mean we learned so much
you know there was many Revelations for
us the extent to which women
um aren't
weren't aren't
um
trusted to make decisions for themselves
in their own lives whether they be
Financial or or reproductive right um
and and and showing that entire paradigm
was was very important to us because
that also sets the stakes right and that
shows
um
it also shows you know what it took for
the women of Jane coming out of being
told that they that they
um weren't as smart or they weren't as
Dependable or they weren't as whatever
whatever the kid may be and as Diane
pointed out you know it does change
within one you know a very short period
of time as far as you know when the
women's movement came into play
um that stuff progressed sort of quickly
but
but the fact that these women were
coming out of a of a time when they were
being told all of those things and had
to overcome that to have confidence in
themselves to then save these women's
lives it becomes even more heroic
you know so I think it's it's important
to it was important to us to show all of
those things and and they were being
marginized not just by the society at
large but by their own movements by the
student movement and the anti-war
movement in the some cases the civil
rights movement and and and and out of
that came you know these fiercely
principled women who had some
significant skills and resources
um and applied them to this direct
action and and and Men worked with them
but they relegated those men to the
helper rules that they had experienced
you know they were the helpers of the
other movements um and so I sort of took
a certain Delight in seeing them
relegate the men to those rules
foreign
so for Diane
if
uh women
today need to form a Jane
uh Collective
to
help people in red States
get abortions
I guess my question is do you think it's
possible that they could make something
like
make a collective like Jane in the 2020s
absolutely
I mean we weren't very special and we
came up with this whole this whole
apparatus
of
training each you know being each
other's friends and mentors and training
each other
um
I feel like if we could do it anyone
could do it really is with determination
and in fact things are happening right
now like there's the group in Chicago uh
we are Jane dot org which is a fantastic
website to look at who's out there doing
um reaching out
wherever they can to help
people that are pregnant find options
um there's the group in in Mexico that's
Distributing pills I mean there's people
doing things right now and I I would say
I only know the tiniest sliver of it
but
I have to tell you that I'm in a group
in Charlotte and I was called the
Reproductive Rights Coalition and in
that group there's someone that's really
um very good with the media and put up
puts up Tic Tacs and I just looked at
the one that they did for the movie and
the background music for it is um
the refrain is let's get it started
again and it just really cracked me up
when I heard it it was uh something by
the Black Eyed Peas it was I just left
I've got to call her up what are you
thinking let's get it started
so there's things happening right now
I'm wondering if you think
the repercussions you know the
repercussions were pretty heavy for The
Janes that in the end
um because you all had to go to jail for
a time I'm wondering
if you think the repercussions
now for people aiding and abetting
abortions are going to be more severe
or does that really depend on who's our
next president
I think the repercussions are were for
me were really minimal I went to jail
for one night I mean that isn't that
isn't much I mean I'm not saying it was
fun or anything but that's really pretty
minimal what people are facing now is so
much worse I mean like
um like the women in Alabama there was
an article in the guardian recently
about the women in Alabama that happened
to be pregnant and are arrested for some
minor uh drug offense and end up jailed
for uh a part of their pregnancies to
supposedly protect the pregnancy and the
the feeling is so awful people are just
so vindictive
um it's so much worse now than it was 50
years ago when I was arrested
well again and I mean some of these laws
are extraordinarily draconian
you know there is a criminalization of
people crossing state lines to provide
abortions so they're
abortion doctors that are never going to
be able to set foot in Texas or Oklahoma
from who live in New York City
um
because they may be prosecuted in in
Texas there's a bounty offered if you
turn in your neighbor or your co-worker
or your family member if you suspect
they're aiding and abetting uh complicit
some way in helping a person get an
abortion so you know that that was never
embedded in these laws before Roe and
now we're talking about a federal
ban a federal abortion ban you know if
the fundamentalists and the extremists
get their way
um
so I think it's quite sobering and you
know but Diane you could have spent 110
years in jail
that's right I mean but you were facing
a lot of prison time and you know thanks
to row you you got off but it didn't it
wasn't necessarily gonna be that way
well yep did you feel
um did it feel pretty serious that you
could face a lot of prison time at that
time
but you have to remember I was very
young and I was very naive I was only
you know in my like 21 22 years old so I
was really young and naive
um I felt at the time looking around my
uh co-defendants as they say you know
the other women I was arrested with I
was a good one to have to go to jail if
anyone did I didn't have children I
didn't have a family that was
particularly worried about me I felt
like well if I had to go to jail because
I did something illegal so be it you
know that's the way it would be
um
that that's how I that's how I felt now
and I still feel that way
um I mean I'm really glad I didn't have
to go to jail because I've had a really
great life but
um people have to accept the
consequences of their of their actions
and I knew exactly what I was doing was
illegal
um
it's so you got so you got off because
Roe void passed and it was no longer
illegal to Performance is that way
that's right we had a bunch of uh Court
appearances
um but eventually it was all dismissed
um
so that was good that was a good thing
but I feel like the um the stakes are so
much higher now they're so much higher
for everyone they're higher for the
pregnant women women that might want the
pregnancy they're having and for some
reason it's it's not safe for them the
baby's dead or that it's an ectopic it's
it's just bad for it it's bad for
everyone now yeah
I'm sorry I think I interrupted you Emma
were you saying something no I was just
reflecting on what Diane was saying
which is you know just the Injustice of
all of that you know that she was
barely 20 Diane is that right yeah yeah
I was a babe feeling it and taking on
her her young shoulders feeling a gap
for the Health Care system because
they're not willing to Value women's
lives so a 20 year old you know she's
here now saying well I would have had to
accept the consequences for my actions
it's just so infuriating that the
consequences for her actions of filling
a void for the U.S government and for
the U.S health care System would could
have possibly been
110 years in prison
and that she had to
accept that as as her as as a notion of
punishment it's just it's just so
backwards and it's and it's hard you
know we we were making working on this
film for a very long time so I think Tia
and I have moments of me of being
shocked that we're in a time where where
something like that
is happening it's not even going to
happen is it is it is happening and that
women are people are gonna be having to
to make these decisions
surprise and the people that it's
impacting the most are low-income people
disproportionately
people of color
and Rural communities and people you
know that haven't had access to abortion
care for many years now
um
so I we we tried to you know we saw that
historically we saw that in the film
when New York legalized abortion who was
left behind in Chicago you know it was
it was low income women it was poor
women it was predominantly black women
um
and it's such an injustice that that is
playing out right now in these states
do you so uh
Tia number do you do you see the film as
being a tool
um or a weapon against
um what is happening right now do you
what are you are you hoping is the
result of people seeing it
yeah go ahead to you well
look films are are ways to engage people
you know emotionally
and in a conversation you know and so we
were we really hope that you know people
are moved you know in some cases and to
laughter in the film that you know also
you know to to really seriously you know
feel
what what it was like then and and what
it may be like now and hopefully engage
in conversation maybe think differently
um maybe it'll move them to go to the
polls this November
um because what's happening on the state
and National level
um is going to make a big difference in
people's lives and women's lives so
there's always that hope but look we
we're we're artists we we can't really
control what people do with what we do
um we can put our work out there as
filmmakers
um
and hope that films like this and other
films
um
can engage people and then you know
whatever they do with it you know
hopefully it's there's some good
um I've seen a lot of films on
different aspects of this subject matter
over the years and some things that I've
seen recently
seem to be trying to give
the pro-life
movements
more of a platform I'm not more of a
platform but
they're showing a lot of footage of of
people on the pro-life side in in saying
you know we really sort of need to
understand more about what we're up
against hmm
um do you have any opinion about whether
you think those kinds of films are very
effective
this keeps coming up it's really
interesting I mean I think what it boils
down to is something that I do believe
in which is is dialogue
um for a healthy Democratic Republic I
think it's important for
different opinions and sides to be to be
trying to understand each other
um that's healthful for us you know I I
do believe that
um
I don't feel like Tia or I felt the need
to both sides it in this film
I don't feel as a documentary filmmaker
that it's a requirement or my
responsibility
um I'm not a news journalist
um you know it didn't really come up we
were telling this story we didn't need
to both sides it the story is the story
that you know this is just full of facts
septic boards across the United States
existed and they were full all the time
and women were dying every day that's
just the facts I don't really even know
how to both sides that yeah
but you know I support dialogue and I
support a well-reasoned
truthful
argument for your opinion or you know I
mean I support all of that
um but it's it's a it's a it's a really
interesting question that I've been
thinking a lot about we got a question
from a journalist recently set talking
about I can't remember which film
um but it was a anti-choice film
um that he said was not very good
he said but what are our boundaries for
what if there was one that that was well
made yeah you know is that going to be
supported by us are we going to watch it
so it's a really interesting question
that I'm I'm really glad we're taught
talking about yes I would just add that
I think that the
the anti-abortion movement has gotten a
disproportionate out of coverage in the
media
um and and you know given that the fact
that the vast majority of people in this
country believe in a woman's right you
know to decide whether and when and with
whom to have a child
um and most people don't even know that
fact that that the anti-abortion
fundamentalist extremists are in in the
minority and yet they have so much
political power they have so much
representation on screen and
um there the images that they've bandied
about the graphic dishonest images of of
fetuses
um
you know have have taken the main stage
and so we're really doing a course
correction here we're telling the
stories of of women
um who have been denied this decision or
have had to fight for their right to
make choices in their lives fundamental
choices about health care
um you know about
about the course that their lives will
take
um and so I I think that there's
it's incumbent on on us to tell these
stories because there's been too much of
the other stories out there in the media
I just want to say I totally agree with
that with what team Emma just said and
and the language this pro-life language
well I'm I'm in favor of life you know
we we're all pro-life and if you think
about this the anti-abortion people is
being in favor of forced childbirth
forced birthing
um no choice anti-choice
um
because abortion is Health Care abortion
we it's so
you know that's so interesting to think
about a good anti-abortion for no reason
I don't even know what that would I know
what that would mean and I give I give
you a lot of credit for being willing to
engage in dialogue because
I have no interest in dialogue at this
point I just
I just say if you don't want to have
enough if you don't like the idea of
abortion then don't have one
um
so for for Diane are you still
involved in activism and
if you haven't been will the current
situation pull you back into activism
well it's kind of funny the way it all
worked out because I was involved in I
became a health care provider and I
worked mostly with people that were
underserved if you call that activism
you know just trying to talk to people
about health care as much as I could and
trying to help them out but I um I moved
to North Carolina I moved to Charlotte
North Carolina and in my desire to get
involved in something I joined a group
that is called the Reproductive Rights
Coalition that in which the members of
the group act as escorts for women going
to abortion clinics
and it was because of that experience
and seeing these fervent
evangelicals who scream at women trying
to enter a clinic to get health care
that I decided to participate in the
movie because I really hadn't even
talked about it
um you know my whole Healthcare you know
my whole life really and since I had
done it so
so now I am active again but I guess I I
would I make a joke that I was like a
sleeper and when it came up you know
um I got involved again and now now I am
that's why I decided to participate in
the movie because of the horrors that I
saw in North Carolina in Charlotte
um people using Bibles to amplify their
voice to yell at women and tell them
that they were going to be going to hell
um that was why I participated in the
movie and that's and that's what I've
been doing with myself lately
thank you so I want to say thank you so
much for making this film and Diane
thank you for
thank you for being a Jane
um
just the the fact of the existence of
this group has uh you know
you listen to the news every day and you
start to feel very down about our
prospects but
this movie made me feel so hopeful about
what
who we really are and what really can be
done so I thank you for that
because getting trapped in the brief in
in the morning of losing our rights is
not going to help us get our rights back
so
thank you so much
um
and
um
thank you for being here and speaking so
eloquently about your film
I wish you good luck on uh award season
thank you and
um thank you so much
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]